[Music]
he was a man of truth of sincerity he
was a man that was dedicated to to the
truth dedicated to the victims and this
is why he went to Baghdad he wanted to
say to the Iraqis you're not alone okay
we as journalists have a noble mission
to tell the truth to tell the story of
your victimization and he lost him his
life in doing this honorable mission
[Music]
economy
that was really a memorable day it seems
that you know a lot of things have Stood
Still from that time just speaking about
about it today you know brings all kinds
of very very sad memories very angry
memories at the same time because when
you're not done you're not done Justice
your wound is still open you you don't
have the time to heal you don't have the
chance to heal you or not offer the
chance to heal
foreign
[Music]
Spirits even if she hasn't seen him so
she felt that she had the duty to carry
on and walk the footsteps of her father
and walk in his shoes seeing her follow
into the footsteps of her father is a
little bit healing because it was always
a kind of you know something worrying
maybe will people forget him will his
memory fade okay uh part part of wanting
to just to hold on to him some way was
through my daughter was through her
foreign
[Music]
every time when there is a war zone you
know the scenario is being repeated all
over again with great suffering you know
when shooting was assassinated in
Palestine
it was like the same day that Tariq was
assassinated people were calling us and
paying their condolences all over again
after 20 years to me at least this is
not a personal issue this is an issue
that has been repeated to a lot of their
a lot of reporters and media personnel
and to their families someone has to
stop that someone should take take a
legal stance because this will be a
discouragement for other reporters to go
and cover War award zones to help people
who are in need for them to tell the
truth to the world
[Music]